that's an example here's my blog circa
an embarrassingly short time ago now if
you resize this window nothing really
changes nothing adjusts other than this
amount of margin space it's really a
fixed width layout now let's take a look
at this on the phone now here I got a
very different version of my blog it
fits well on the phone but I'm only
getting this because my blog is running
out of WordPress and WordPress is
configured to give a totally different
version to phones but that's not
actually what I want because I really
want to have a shared layout between the
two let's take a look at this on an
intermediate device my 7-inch Android
tablet now here what I'm getting is
essentially the desktop version I can
still scroll through the site but you
can tell all the text is pretty small
although interestingly if I rotate to
landscape mode it adapts now why does it
do that
well it turns out it's our old friend
viewport there's no viewport set on this
page so what does that mean
does layout happen at the device width
or just layout happen at the magic 980
pixel width and then get rescaled to fit
on the screen